en este vídeo aprenderemos a dividir
polinomios el método que vamos a ver se
conoce como división larga vamos a hacer
algunos ejemplos para ver de qué se
trata sale vamos a empezar con uno muy
sencillo que dice haz la división 2 x +
4 entre entre 2 en realidad ya sabemos
cómo hacer esta división verdad podemos
dividir el numerador y el denominador
entre 2 para simplificar la y vamos a
ver que nos queda en realidad no estamos
cambiando el valor nada más estamos
cambiando cómo lo expresamos verdad
entonces dividiendo el numerador entre 2
nos queda x + 2 tiene 2 x entre 12 x 4
entre 12 2 y dividiendo el numerador
entre 2 nos queda 1 entonces esta
división es igual a x + 2 entonces eso
es con herramientas que ya tenemos
también podríamos haber actualizado un 2
del numerador y luego lo que observamos
con el denominador eso también
funcionaba pero vamos a ver cómo podemos
resolver este problema utilizando
división larga va a ser un cañonazo para
este problema porque pues es una técnica
muy sofisticada
en realidad es para ver que no es algo
está tremendamente nuevo y después vamos
a ver cómo se puede utilizar para
problemas un poco más complicados pero
bueno vamos con este entonces la idea es
poner aquí el 2 afuera porque estamos
dividiendo entre 2 aquí ponemos nuestra
casita de división y aquí adentro
ponemos 2 x más 4
entonces nos preguntamos cuántas veces
cabe este 2 en 2 x pues cabe x veces
porque 2 x entre 2 es x verdad entonces
aquí arriba ponemos una x la voy a poner
así con color azul x entonces ahora
hacemos x por 2 es 2 x 2 x y restamos
entonces le voy a poner aquí un menos 2
x menos 2 x se cancela y ahora baja este
4 baja el 4
cuántas veces cabe el 2 en el 4 pues dos
veces entonces aquí le ponemos más +2 y
hacemos dos por dos es cuatro restamos
estos dos números y aquí nos queda cero
entonces justo la división de 2 x + 4
entre 2 es igual a x + 2 que es lo mismo
que ya habíamos hecho esto parece muy
sofisticado pero vamos a ver que es un
proceso más generalizable o sea que
funciona para dividir cualesquiera dos
polinomios bueno déjame pasar abajo para
ver otro ejemplo
entonces imagina que queremos realizar
la división x cuadrada x cuadrada más 3
x + 3 x 6 y eso / dividido entre le voy
a poner x + 1 va x + 1 entonces cuando
tenemos ahora grados mayores no nos
vamos a preguntar cuántas veces cabe x +
1 en todo esto sino que nada más nos
fijamos en los términos de mayor grado
aquí sería este x y aquí sería este x al
cuadrado entonces la pregunta sería
cuántas veces cabe x en x al cuadrado
pues cabe x veces verdad x al cuadrado
entre x es x
entonces esa x la voy a poner aquí en
donde está el lugar de las x es
ahí está la equis y hacemos la
multiplicación x x x es x cuadrada
x x 1 es x va y que hacemos ahora pues
vamos a restar entonces nos quedaría - x
cuadrado menos x entonces le voy a poner
así la línea para que restamos esto se
cancelan 3 x x 2 x 2 x y finalmente el 6
no le restamos nada y baja como 6 baja
como 6 todavía no hemos terminado porque
x todavía cabe en este término de aquí
en este 2 x y cuántas veces cabe pues 2
verdad 2 x entre x es 2 entonces aquí le
pongo más 2 muy bien ahora este 2
multiplica el x 1
nos queda 2x aquí 2 x 1 es 2 y restamos
menos menos entonces vamos a hacer la
resta 2 x 2 x se cancela 6 menos dos es
cuatro y observa el x ya no cabe en el 4
porque éste ya tiene grado mayor que el
4 entonces este 4 es el residuo el
residuo de nuestra división entonces
déjame reescribir esta operación para
que quede un poco más claro
lo que hicimos lo que acabamos de ver es
básicamente que exista al cuadrado más
13 x + 6 / / / x 1 / x más uno es igual
a x2 x + 2 y sobraron 4 o sea sobran 4
divididos entre x + 1 vale entonces esto
es la parte que corresponde al residuo y
para verificar que está de adeveras es
una igualdad que estas dos expresiones
son equivalentes podríamos desarrollar
el lado derecho para ver que
regresáramos acá lo que tenemos que
hacer es estas sumas de fracciones
entonces ponemos que tengan denominador
común multiplicamos aquí por x + 1 y
dividimos entre x + 1
y sumamos 4 / x + 1 entonces si haces
esta multiplicación y le sumas el 4
deberías regresar a equis cuadradas más
3 x + 6 esto está muy divertido verdad
vamos a hacer otro más vamos a hacer
otro más entonces éste dice ahora
imagínate que empiezan dándonos la
expresión x cuadrada más 5 x más 4 + 4 y
esa la queremos dividir entre x 4 x + 4
muy bien pues hacemos nuestra división
de casita estamos dividiendo entre x + 4
/ x + 4
4 la expresión x cuadrada + 5 x + 4 muy
bien entonces primera pregunta cuántas
veces cabe xx cuadrada pues cabe cabe x
veces que x cuadrada entre xx muy bien
este x multiplica x 4 x x x x cuadrada x
x 4 es 4x y ahora tenemos que restar
menos menos hacemos la resta
x cuadrada - x cuadrada déjame poner
esto en otro color lo voy a poner con
color naranja entonces este se cancela 5
x menos 4 x aquí nos queda x y aquí
vamos a ponerle más 4 porque el 4 baja
no le estamos restando nada entonces
bueno a lo mejor aquí puedes ver
directamente que x + 4 cabe una vez en x
+ 4 pero vamos a hacer de cuenta que no
nos dimos cuenta de eso y vamos a
ponerle cuántas veces cabe x en x cabe
justo una vez verdad entonces ahora
multiplicamos 1 por x 4 es x + 4 x + 4
pero tenemos que restar entonces voy a
poner el x y el 4 tenemos que restar y
hacemos la resta y nos queda justamente
muy bien entonces como el residuo es 0
quiere decir que ya no nos va a sobrar
nada y por lo tanto esta división x
cuadrada más 5 x + 4 entre 4 es igual a
x + 1 x + 1 este problema pudimos
haberlo resuelto de otra forma pudimos
haber intentado factorizar el numerador
por ejemplo es decir que x cuadrada más
5 x más 4 entre x 4
es igual a x4 por x1 ahí está la
factorización entre x4 entonces pudimos
haber factor izado esto de golpe
pero bueno eso requiere mucha
inspiración verdad y bueno en efecto si
da o sea cuatro por una es 4 y 4 15
entonces y ahí está la factorización
pero ahí requeríamos pues mucha
inspiración y también necesitábamos que
por casualidad el residuo fuera 0
entonces bueno gracias a eso en efecto
cancelando este con este nos queda x + 1
pero bueno o sea ambas ambos métodos
funcionan en este caso pero la división
larga funciona incluso aunque la
división no sea exacta aunque este
residuo no nos haya quedado cero bueno
vamos a hacer otro más otro más un poco
más complicado porque esta es una
herramienta súper útil súper útil para
para varias cosas matemáticas a las
cuales te vas a enfrentar después
entonces hagamos un poco más complicado
con polinomios de grado 3 y 2 entonces
imagínate que queremos dividir 3 x al
cubo menos 2 x cuadrada
+ 7 x menos cuatro menos cuatro entre
entre y aquí le voy a poner x cuadrada
más uno va ahora parece un poco
complicado pero es exactamente la misma
idea déjame poner nuestra casita para
realizar la división entonces afuera
tenemos no voy a poner aquí abajo afuera
tenemos x cuadrada más 1 estamos
dividiendo entre x cuadrada más 1 y
adentro tenemos 3 x al cubo 3 x al cubo
menos 2 x cuadrada más 7 x 17 x menos 4
muy bien entonces ahora cuántas veces
cabe x cuadrada en 3 x al cubo
bueno pues cuando cuanto es 3 x al cubo
entre x al cuadrado el el 3 queda no se
cancela con nada y el x al cubo entre x
cuadrada es x entonces son 3 x dejarme
lo escribo por acá entonces le voy a
poner
es 3x y lo pongo en la columna que le
corresponde 3x muy bien entonces ahora
3x x x cuadrada más 1 cuando es pues es
3x cúbica 3x cúbica 3x x uno es 3x no lo
pongo aquí sino en la columna que le
corresponde entonces le voy a poner 3x y
tenemos que restar restamos
vamos a ver cuánto nos quedan vamos a
ver cuántos nos quedan este se cancela
con este menos dos equis cuadrada no le
estamos restando nada quedan como menos
dos equis cuadrada 7x menos tres equis
es 4x
4x muy bien y finalmente hay que bajar
este menos cuatro menos 4 excelente
vamos a otro color que ya está todo muy
azul vamos a color rojo digamos entonces
ahora cuántas veces cabe x cuadrada en
menos 2 x cuadrada pues cabe menos dos
veces que menos dos por equis cuadrada
es menos 2x cuadrada
menos dos por uno es menos dos los menos
dos y ahora tenemos que dividir perdón
tenemos que restar y como estamos
restando este se hace más y éste se hace
más estos se cancelan aquí nos queda 4x
y aquí nos queda menos 42 que es menos 2
muy bien entonces déjame reescribir esto
ya nada más en la forma en la que nos
queda y pues para terminar con un color
verde
entonces que nos quedaría nos quedaría
que la división es igual a 3 x menos 2 y
tenemos un residuo
y este es recibo porque x cuadrada ya no
caben 4 x x cuadrada ya es de grado
mayor entonces estoy aquí ya es el
residuo voy a poner así residuo
vale entonces el residuo sería más 4 x
menos 2 dividido
dividido entre x cuadrada x cuadrada más
punto bueno espero que te parezcan tan
divertidos como a mí nos vemos en los
siguientes vídeos